voici bros wii nice
bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'avoir choisi mon enfant
nous sommes très heureux que vous soyez
là ce soir je faisais un peu est ce que
vous vous êtes heureux à paris
dies 20 super super heureux j'adore
paris j'aime toujours venir ici les gens
sont toujours très sympa avec moi je
connais l'hôtel l'hôtel vous êtes
installé brouille c'est un très bon
hôtel situé à saint antoine
c'est un très bon hôtel très bien situé
bonne cuisine
voilà alors comment ça va avec les
parisiennes tout tout tout vraiment tout
deal
malheureusement qu'est ce que vous
faites après l'émission moi je connais
des endroits je suis mal et je peut vous
amener après l'émission
ok est ce que vous pourriez vivre en
france bruce oui sans aucun doute jeu
pour éviter à paris sans aucun doute à
limoges
you know limoges away note limoges
spèce vous apprendriez le français si
vous habitiez en france via sa oui j'ai
pas l'air sur la home depot qui est
apparue s'y attendait c'est à la tour
eiffel
alors
c'est bruce willis habiter en france il
pourrait faire des films avec laurent
baffie ce directeur à give you my love
and roll vous avez une carte non
enlèvement my movies ok go l'assistant
mon film des sceaux
tu aimerais bien alors toute façon bruce
willis n'a rien contre les réalisateurs
français puisque vous avez fait le
cinquième élément
avec luc besson et que votre nouveau
film otages et réalisé par florent syrie
alors conservez vous êtes l'auteur denis
jet sorti en 2002 avec benoît magimel
samy naceri nadia farès qui est venu
d'ailleurs ici pour ans pour en parler
et ce film nid de guêpes bruce willis
l'a vu à l'american film market et il a
été intéressé par votre travail
comment s'est passée votre première
rencontre à revoir ça s'est très bien
passé vraiment bien passé il m'a appelé
tout simplement il m'a laissé un message
sur mon répondeur je les ai rappelés on
s'est vus à los angeles
et puis voilà ça doit faire un drôle
d'effet quand même non ben oui surtout
quand on est fan de films américains et
de bruce willis en particulier moi j'ai
grandi avec bruce willis
voilà donc c'était ouais c'était super
pour moi alors vous savez également
votre premier film qui s'appelle une
minute de silence qui est consacré aux
mineurs à la frontière franco-allemande
et il vous a dit je suis comme toi on
vient du même milieu
ouais en fait sa job
oui moi je viens de new jersey cela
aussi c'est une région tout à fait
similaire il ya aussi beaucoup d' usine
beaucoup de travailleurs d'employés
d'ouvriers
oui vous êtes né en allemagne quand vous
étiez petit votre père était mécanicien
sur une base américaine en allemagne
donc vous avez connu la vie
mais vous savez ça vous est absolument
c'est tout
alors voilà quelques mois plus tard
florent vous avez reçu le scénario deux
otages quinze jours plus tard j'étais en
train de travailler à hollywood et donc
par aman ne voulait pas un réalisateur
dans ce soit le premier film américain
et à ce moment-là bruce willis vous a
soutenu c'est à dire qu'il a dit
apparemment mme banon si vous voulez pas
de flore en syrie tant pis pour vous et
il a récolté comme ça sur quelques coups
de téléphone 53 millions de dollars pas
mal il ya des copains qui sont riches
ouais non mais sérieusement c'est très
courageux de votre part parce que il ya
des gens à votre place qu'aurait dit
tant pis je choisis par la montée je
laisse tomber florence hier non non moi
ce qui m'intéressait c'était plutôt
florent plutôt que la paramount les
studios bon ça va ça vient mais des
types comme florent et croyez moi c'est
plus rare alors c'est super
impressionnant mais de le diriger à un
mythe américain vivante c'est john wayne
voilà pour moi qui lycéen peut s'arrêter
faire mon premier film américain avec
bruce willis était un peu moi diriger
dans ma tête john wayne puisqu'il est un
peu cette image il préfère qu'ils osent
pas mal aussi oui on pourrait dire ça
oui
alors l'histoire c'était un ancien
négociateur qui a quitté le métier après
une prise d'otage qui a mal tourné il
est devenu flic dans une ville
tranquille et il va avoir à gérer une
nouvelle prise d'otage plus une deuxième
prise d'otage simultanées dont sont
victimes
sa femme et sa fille voilà donc c'était
une prise d'otages dans la prise
d'otages c'est un scénario assez
sophistiqué assez haletant c'est du vrai
cinéma du samedi soir tu l'as vu laurent
ouais j'ai beaucoup aimé un vrai vrai
film d'action un début assez hard c'est
quand même mordant français c'est pour
passer ce cap stressant et c'est très
bien écrit et très très bien filmé et
très bien joué engagé un modèle du genre
pour moi voilà ça c'est bien moi
j'essaie de c'était un peu le film
américain que j'avais envie de voir le
film d'action américain que j'avais
envie de voir
je n'ai pas vu depuis longtemps parce
qu'il trouvait que les films d'action
américains étaient un peu formaté et
celui-là retourner un peu aux sources du
genre avec des vrais parcours de
personnages alors on va voir à quoi ça
ressemble vous allez regarder tous les
deux votre caméra et vous allez dire
magnéto serge ouaddou magnéto serge
10h02
son ami authentique
[Musique]
le sont allés tu va me sauver je vais
vous sauver des vies il faut qu'on
essaie de sauver le gosse on n'a pas de
choix
merde seigneur aussi sa protection
je pense que je suis en retard
et si on disait l'a dit pas de délit
suivi par hardy validé
[Applaudissements]
tammy pas mais qu est-ce qu ici
l'officier flores que la police de
bristo camino et silencieuse a été
déclenchée
geste les est-ce qu'ils vont s'en sortir
bonne chance je vais plus sur le coup le
shérif est repris à faire
[Musique]
c'est pas de ta faute si elle est morte
tiff
[Musique]
on a un problème on doit reprendre le
contrôle de cette situation
je veux que vous retournez chez vous
attend ce soir il ya un dvd dans sa
maison m'appartiennent si vous ne faites
pas exactement ce que je vous en prie je
tuerai votre famille
les plus communs
je voudrais avoir un autre enfant mort
sur la conscience
j'ai besoin de tourner
oui très bon mois
très sûr vu mes enfants
notre lancée et bruce willis
or voilà
beckham des personnages
ces nouveaux avec des personnages de
méchants très nouveau parce qu'au lieu
de prendre des mecs comme ça
là c'est plutôt des jeunes un peu white
trash quoi donc c'est très moderne
ça s'est bien passé avec bruce il a été
docile super vraiment j'ai rien à dire
c'était d'abord une super
[Musique]
comment dirais-je rencontre plus qu'une
rencontre c'est devenu un ami c'est
quelqu'un de très ouvert très simple il
m'a vraiment laissé faire le film que je
voulais faire c'était important c'est
vrai qu'un jour leur un peu poussé dans
ses retranchements et vous a dit hu
c'est florent je les fais 50 films et
vous lui aurait répondu moi j'en retiens
que quatre c'est pas tout est secret
story non c'est pas la vérité c'est
vraiment très bien entendu alors la
fille de bruce willis rumer willis joue
dans le film est ce que vous pensez
qu'elle va faire une carrière
ouais moi je suis sûr qu'elle va faire
une carrière mais qu'est ce qu'on tente
votre fille j'en suis oui elle veut en
tout cas fait rire vraiment été super
dans le film comme j'étais producteur du
film je lui fait faire une audition et
donc elle est venue elle a rencontré
florent et donc c'est elle qui a
remporté le le rôle mais bon les
toujours c'est toujours une gamine et
s'il veut vraiment faire carrière
devenir actrice et bien je les trouve
alors règle absolue vos enfants n'ont le
droit de faire du cinéma que si vous ou
démis moore jouer dans le film quoi ils
ont pas droit de faire des films sans
vous effectivement ils peuvent
travailler avec leur père avec leur mère
et pour nous ça nous permet de les
maintenir enfants mais bon ils se sont
vraiment éclaté en faisant ça ils
grandissent beaucoup en faisant ça
pendant les tournages que ce soit avec
leur mère aux rythmes d'ailleurs
l'impression de vous donner en tous les
cas avec demi moore
vous êtes séparé mais l'impression que
vous donnez c'est d'arriver à préserver
très bien vos enfants on n'a pas
l'impression qu'ils qui souffre de sa
merci effectivement on est toujours amis
avec des mines
un très bon ami et donc quand on sait
par et on s'est mis d'accord pour
essayer de faire preuve d'intelligence
et de protéger nos enfants avant tout et
pour l'instant je veux dire que ça fort
bien marché on est restés amis c'est
vraiment une très bonne chose pour les
enfants et donc ça marche mieux
c'est un demi divorce en fait alors
depuis que vous êtes séparés on vous
prête
bruce willis est normal c'est très beau
on vous prête toutes sortes d'aventurés
récemment vous avez été obligé de
démentir une liaison avec une starlette
de 18 ans qui s'appelle lindsay lohan
alors aux yeux c'est vrai il ya très peu
de choses qu'on peut faire quand on est
là quand on est aussi connue parce que
les gens vont toujours partir d'un
moment un autre donc là j'étais un petit
peu trop loin peut-être et donc ils les
ont poursuivis en justice ils ont du
punch et présenté leurs excuses mais bon
eu 18 ans et c'était un peu trop jeune
peut-être à vous dites toute façon je
devenu tellement difficile maintenant
qu'il ya que 2 % de la population
féminine dans le monde qui peut me
correspond donc c'est très difficile
pour vous maintenant de trouver
chaussure à votre pied comme on dit oui
c'est très difficile effectivement mais
bon je cherche
d'accord mais les filles maintenant vous
le savez estinnes look et voilà alors
vous dites c'est difficile de savoir en
fait quand on voit arriver une fille
quand on est bruce willis parce que il
ya écrit jackpot ici et c'est très
compliqué de savoir si la fille est
honnête c'est ça avance et un pseudo
aubry
oui je suis le jackpot incarner oui
je sais pas en tout cas je pense que
c'est une question de confiance
tu n'as pas envie d'avoir une aventure
avec une mass eye pour voir un peu un
regard vierge quelqu'un qui ne te
connais pas oui une inuit
mais non non je ne veux pas il ya un
truc très très drôle bruce willis etc
récemment dans le show de david
letterman à new york
vous avez sorti un dvd aux 4,7 avec la
vie sexuelle la vie sexuelle autorisée
c'est quoi c'est à dire que les les
bandes qui était sûr sur internet vous
avez décidé de les sortir en dvd c'est
sa vie sexuelle de bruce willis
il faut 5 dvd
merci c'était simplement la première
année
m
c'était moi qui chante et ça fait chaud
au coeur
ça s'appelait la
ça s'appelait le retour de bruno données
turn of honor et beaucoup chanté plus
maintenant si si je chante toujours jeu
je me produis avec mon groupe qui
s'appelle célébrités 3 on est allé en
irak pour amuser ses troupes
mais c'est un petit secret quelque chose
que je fais toujours je fait différent
je fais la musique tout à fait
différente maintenant là ce qu'on a
entendu ça remonte à 18 heures hé bien
sûr et bien sûr alors avec otages bruce
willis vous redevenez un héros donc on
va faire une interview antihéros
[Musique]
boucherie c est ce que vous avez déjà
fermer votre gueule devant un flic qui
vous connaît un pv ouais
est-ce que vous avez déjà fermer votre
gueule devant un flic qui s'en prenait à
un black
alors pour excuse moi le chèque bruce
willis hockey
est-ce que vous avez déjà fermer votre
gueule devant un flic qui s'en prenaient
un black à nom est devant un blague qui
s'en prenait à un flux est ce que vous
avez déjà fait semblant de ne pas
entendre quelqu'un qui vous avait
insulté alors oui vous êtes déjà évanoui
on va voir parce que nous ça nous
arrange vachement que ce soit un anti
héros quand est-ce que vous avez déjà
porter des chaussettes trouées par
exemple oui et des slips salle non
est-ce que vous avez déjà exigé un
cascadeur pour une scène pourtant sans
danger
ah non vous avez déjà demandé à des
techniciens de sortir du plateau au
moment où vous alliez vous mettre tout
nu vous ai déjà eu une panne sexuelle
avec une femme très entreprenante
non c'est un héros
est-ce que vous avez déjà serré la main
de quelqu'un en sachant qu'il vous
détestez et qui sortait des toilettes
sans salle à belem est ce que vous êtes
déjà barré avant qu'une de vos conquêtes
ne se réveille
j'ai crié non seulement du doigt le
matin est ce que vous êtes
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà dit à une
fille que c'était la femme de votre vie
pour coucher plus vite avec elle js j'ai
déjà profité qu'une fille soit bourré
pour coucher avec m
oui voilà gros service
ailleurs
non
des cabanes grosse crise florent vous
devez vous laisser embrasser sur la
bouche par thierry ardisson les cartons
et c'est moi ça me plairait
c'est la peine de mort
[Applaudissements]
m
à y déléguer des biens des nues
et des millions de suie qui m'envient ce
soir à lorient le sexe est un vrai héros
cesse avec sur les vidéos pcx savez je
sais pas si je passe mon tour j'attends
julia roberts hockey 5e
merci
[Musique]
voilà donc les inattendus m'embrasser
sur la bouche celles qui veulent essayer
là encore un petit peu de pays est
encore un petit coup de brosse minutes
j'ai essayé et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux